bonjour Marc feno bonjour plusieurs
centaines de manifestants
d'ultra-droites ont défilé samedi
dernier à Paris certains sous des
cagoules avec des croix celtiques est-ce
que vous comprenez que la préfecture est
laissée faire la préfecture elle
s'inscrit dans dans l'État de droit
comme sur toutes les manifestations
c'est une manifestation qui a été
déclarée
de deuxièmement c'est une manifestation
qui n'avait pas donné lieu les années
précédentes à des troubles à l'ordre
public alors dire ça c'est pas forcément
satisfaisant maintenant on est dans
l'État de droit puisqu'on sait très bien
que tout est décisions préfectorales ça
arrive d'ailleurs que les décisions
d'interdiction préfectorales soient
cassée au motif que il y a pas de de
troubles manifeste à l'ordre public et
troubles avéré ou potentiel à l'ordre
public et donc ça oblige à autoriser ces
manifestations est-ce qu'on peut
manifester avec des cagoules aujourd'hui
en France mais pas avec des casseroles
non on peut manifester avec des cagoules
on peut manifester aussi d'ailleurs avec
des casseroles puisque il y a des tas
d'endroits où moi-même je me déplace où
il y a des gens qui ont des casseroles
c'est le trouble alors de public c'est
pas la nature la manifestation après il
y a un deuxième sujet qui est la nature
de des messages qui sont véhiculés dans
ce type de manifestation on peut pas
dire que le gouvernement là-dessus ne
soit en retard de la main on a dit sous
un certain nombre de groupuscules
d'extrême droite je pense aux oive de
Paris c'est comme ça qui s'appelle je
crois qui ont été dissous aux motifs
qu'il véhiculé des théories
néo-nazies ou d'extrême droite donc il y
a deux de combat amener un il faut
travailler dans le cadre de l'État de
droit parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
doit travailler quand on est sur les
autorisations de manifester puis deux
combattre ces idées là le cas échéant
quand elles sont à ce point
véhicules de pensée terrible de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse toutes ces mouvements
s'il y a lieu les dissoudre est-ce qu'à
force de taper sur l'ultra gauche vous
avez oublié l'ultra droite non pas du
tout non pas du tout on peut on a le
droit d'être symétrique dans ce registre
là et de dire que les deux engendrent
souvent les mêmes choses c'est-à-dire de
la violence du rejet évite que dans ce
pays on puisse se parler et moi j'ai
toujours été tout à fait symétrique dans
ces jeunes je ne trie pas dans les les
extrêmes et je ne trie pas dans les
violences la violence est condamnable
l'appel à la violence et condamnable que
ce soit d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche ou d'ailleurs au fond c'est pas
le sujet je pense que c'est la violence
et ce qu'on dit qui compte et parce
qu'on est qui compte uniquement Marc
fedo ça fait un an maintenant
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été réélu à
l'Elysée Elizabeth borde fêtera le même
anniversaire la semaine prochaine à
Matignon comme à l'école vous mettriez
que l'appréciation très bien bien peu
mieux faire ou nul non on est pardon on
n'est pas à l'école ça me fait penser à
l'école des pas de même j'ai cru que
j'allais dire
avec des bonnes notes parfois il y avait
des enfants qui étaient un peu distraits
de cette on a essayé depuis un an de
faire face à deux sujets qui sont un
sujet d'un pays qui profondément est en
tension de sur un tas de sujet on voit
bien qu'on va parler d'autre sujet tout
à l'heure j'imagine on a du mal à
essayer de trouver une forme de
compromis sur un certain nombre de
sujets dans ce pays puis deux un pays
qui a traversé des crises gilets jaunes
des crises covid et des crises
ukrainiennes avec des éléments de
d'inflation et la première ministre sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
a déployé un certain nombre de mesures à
la fois sur les questions d'inflation à
la fois sur les questions qui tiennent
ton retraite puisque ça occupait
beaucoup l'automne et le printemps vous
le savez aussi bien que moi si c'était
mieux que moi et donc c'est plutôt dans
ce registre là qu'il faut regarder
ce sont les problèmes extérieurs qui
engendre cette ambiance dans le pays non
non les Français disent que non non
je n'ai pas dit que c'est non je n'ai
pas dit que c'était les problèmes
extérieurs qui engendrés je dis qu'on
nous sommes dans un pays qui est dans
cet état de tension on va parler
d'agriculture je dis pas que c'est
extérieur qui viennent créer ces
tensions autour du sujet agricole on a
besoin dans ce pays d'essayer sur un
certain nombre de sujets de trouver des
voies de compromis et d'essayer
d'avancer et c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
faire depuis un an je dis pas que les
choses sont pas faites je n'ai jamais
dit que les choses n'étaient pas faites
d'ailleurs personne au gouvernement ne
le dit comme ça on essaie d'avancer de
faire face et d'armer le pays au fond
face aux crises intérieures et face aux
crises ça veut dire quoi que les
Français vous comprennent pas non il
faut jamais penser quand quelque chose
n'est pas compris que c'est la faute de
vos interlocuteurs il faut sans doute
s'interroger soi-même sur qu'est-ce
qu'on dit comment on peut le dire donc
les Français sans doute que sur la
question des retraites Simon interrogé
sur cette question là on a eu du mal à
poser le débat qui était un débat à mon
avis d'équilibre des comptes alors je
suis assez fasciné de dire que
maintenant j'entends même le corps dire
que finalement peut-être que les comptes
n'étaient pas équilibrés enfin bref on a
du mal à documenter la réalité des
choses on aura du mal à avancer dans ce
pays si on n'arrive pas à dire ce
qu'elle est à des lieux du moment
François Bayrou votre patron en quelque
sorte le patron du MoDem marque fenot
disait sur ce plateau il y a quelques
semaines cette réforme n'est pas tout à
fait la mienne on aurait dû la faire
différemment on aurait dû notamment
taxer
les patrons via les cotisations
patronales c'est votre avis c'est pas
tout à fait les échanges que je vais
transformer ou François est-ce qu'il a
dit en Belgique
j'essaie de répondre à votre question
néanmoins et il disait à juste titre je
crois qu'on a eu du mal ce que je répète
à dire ce qui était l'état du déficit
actuel est-ce que on voulait faire au
travers de cette rideaux sources de
financement de financement mais la
source principale on sait bien que c'est
la mesure d'âge d'ailleurs c'est pas
très original parce que c'est des
mesures qui sont prises dans tous les
pays européens alors on peut toujours
penser qu'en France on est très
différent des autres et très différent
de gens qui sont quelques centaines de
kilomètres de ici à Paris enfin il me
semble que c'est pas très original de ce
point là en revanche on a on n'a pas
réussi à dire ce qui était l'enjeu un
d'équilibre et l'enjeu d'équilibre il
est pas pour l'équilibre comme une Maroc
il est un enjeu aussi le souveraineté
quand vous n'êtes pas capable de payer
ou d'assurer les pensions de retraite de
votre de vos concitoyens et que vous
devez faire de la dette pour les payer
vous avez un enjeu de souveraineté parce
que quand vous êtes dans les mains de
vos créanciers vous avez un problème de
souveraineté comme quand vous êtes dans
les mains de votre banquier totalement
en plus alors c'est pas terminé sur la
réforme des en plus des syndicats qui
veulent pas lâcher l'affaire il y a
aussi les députés du groupe indépendant
liotte qui ont déposé une proposition de
loi visant à abroger le report de l'âge
légal à 64 ans et à accélérer et mettre
fin aussi à l'accélération de la durée
de cotisation certains à droite comme
Aurélien Pradier pourrait voter 10
vouloir voter cette proposition de loi
comme la gauche c'est une nouvelle
inquiétude pour le gouvernement quel
sera votre l'attitude de la majorité
est-ce qu'il y aura de l'obstruction si
jamais alors attendez je suis jamais
inquiète du débat j'ai été ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement je suis
jamais inscrit inquiet du débat au
Parlement enfin je veux dire on n'a pas
avoir peur des parlementaires
ni nos concitoyens après pardon est-ce
que la majorité a le droit de faire des
amendements et de poser ses propres
termes vous avez eu sur la réforme des
retraites 40000 amendements je crois pas
que ça soit le sujet de la majorité sur
cette niche mais est-ce qu'on a le droit
quand même quand on est dans la majorité
de dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord et de
poser des amendements à partir de
combien d'amendements considérera que
c'est une obstruction enfin je veux dire
on a le droit de poser des amendements
je vous pose la question différemment
est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'on aille au
vote sur cette proposition je souhaite
qu'on débattre je sais pas si c'est un
vote on est dans une allée faire ce que
vous avez reproché aux oppositions
excusez-moi on a débattu quasiment trois
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale là vous
pensez qu'on va régler cette enfin soit
c'est une question sérieuse et on
considère qu'une journée c'est peut-être
un peu court mais allons-y ce n'est pas
la première fois que dans une niche je
le dis je le répète comme ancien
ministre de relation avec le Parlement
on met des tests comme si c'était en une
journée que les sujets pouvaient se
trancher alors j'entends plus que
j'entends non mais oui très bien article
1 je supprime les impôts article 2
comment je les finance enfin je veux
dire on peut aussi faire un article il y
a quand même question de responsabilité
quand on est parlementaire et donc sur
le texte en l'occurrence de Dieu
j'entends qu'il revienne de 64 à 62 et
que deux ils reviennent sur la Touraine
qui n'a pas été votée par ce
gouvernement et par les socialistes
la durée de cotisation vous estimez
qu'une journée c'est trop comment
c'est peut-être pas inintéressant dans
un débat même de 12 heures à l'Assemblée
nationale de est-ce qu'ils sont capables
dans cette niche de garantir les
pensions de retraite sans augmenter les
cotisations et sans baisser les pensions
de retraite je veux dire ça mérite comme
un débat sérieux on n'est pas je sais
qu'on est dans un monde médiatique je
parle pas ici en tant que tel hein mais
où il suffit de cliquer de claquer des
doigts pour essayer d'apporter des
réponses en tout cas c'est pas ma façon
c'est pas notre façon de recevoir les
choses c'est un débat sérieux il y aura
un débat on a le droit quand on est même
dans la majorité de poser des
amendements et de dire on n'est pas
d'accord on verra on verra c'est pas moi
qui suis l'accélération des débats et la
façon dont ils se déroule marque phéno
vous restez avec nous dans un instant on
va parler d'un sujet qui intéresse et
qui inquiète une bonne partie des
Français c'est la sécheresse déjà en
cours dans de nombreux départements par
la situation des agriculteurs également
le fil info tout d'abord à 8h40 avec
Maureen Suire
[Musique]
court devant des milliers de soldats sur
la Place Rouge à Moscou discours de
Vladimir Poutine à l'occasion du
traditionnel défilé pour célébrer la
victoire contre l'Allemagne nazie mais
cette année le président russe doit
faire avec les difficultés de son armée
en Ukraine ce matin keV affirme avoir
intercepté une vingtaine de missiles de
croisière russe augmenter de 25% les
contrôles fiscaux sur les plus gros
patrimoines d'ici la fin du quinquennat
voici l'objectif du ministre des comptes
publics Gabriel Attal présente
aujourd'hui son plan pour lutter contre
la fraude qui représente jusqu'à 100
milliards d'euros chaque année ils sont
7 anciens collaborateurs à dénoncé du
harcèlement moral l'ex député la
République en marche Laetitia avia et
jugée à partir d'aujourd'hui devant le
tribunal correctionnel de Paris les
plaignants dénoncent des humiliations
des propos à caractère sexistes
homophobe voire raciste au Canada les
flammes sont toujours là 400 000
hectares de forêt brûlées en quelques
jours seulement dans la province de
l'Alberta c'est 6 fois plus plus que
tous les feux de forêt en France l'année
dernière
France Info
le 8 30 France Info Salia brachiha MC
Fauvelle
et de la souveraineté alimentaire Marc
féno depuis l'été dernier la sécheresse
s'est installée dans le pays la plus
fait rare des dizaines de départements
sont en alerte à combien s'élève les
pertes de récolte vous avez déjà fait un
état des lieux non alors pardon d'être
un peu pragmatique dans ce genre
d'exercice vous ne pouvez connaître
l'état des lieux de la perte de récolte
que quand vous avez récolté c'est un peu
une évidence
vous faites pas de l'anticipation sur la
biologie des plantes je veux dire ou
s'il y a plus d'eau du tout on perd tous
il y a de l'eau et qui manifestement
qu'en particulier ce matin et depuis
quelques semaines il y a beaucoup de
territoires en France où il pleut et
plus de façon satisfaisante dans mon
propre département on a une pluviométrie
qui est plutôt satisfaisante j'étais
l'autre jour dans une région on disait
il y a même un peu trop de pluviométrie
donc la météo n'est pas une science que
nous maîtrisons et peut-être que c'est
mieux ainsi d'ailleurs sans doute que
c'est mieux ainsi ça veut pas dire que
on va y revenir il y a pas des
départements qui sont sous gros stress
justement
le week-end dernier vous avez annoncé
aux agriculteurs qu'une indemnisation
leur à quelles conditions
c'est dans le cadre de la réforme de
l'assurance récolte et heureusement
qu'on a fait ça qui était sans doute
dans une forme d'impasse
il y a la solidarité assurantielle qui
va jouer pour ceux qui sont assurés puis
pardon par ailleurs la solidarité
nationale qui viendra couvrir une partie
des pertes que pourrait rencontrer les
arboriculteurs les viticulteurs les
maraîchers on est plutôt sur ce type de
culture dans ce département là et donc
c'est l'idée c'est de dire qu'on sera à
leur côté comment l'a été d'ailleurs sur
la grêle sur le gel et sur la sécheresse
l'été passé après on a un sujet qui est
bien plus terrible dans un département
comme celui-là parce que c'est pas
simplement la perte de récolte qu'on a
c'est parfois la perte des arbres
fruitiers on a entendu des
arboriculteurs dire certains doivent
jeter la récolte en cours aujourd'hui si
un arboriculteur perd ses arbres sous
l'effet d'une course
est-ce qu'on l'aide à les replanter ou
est-ce qu'on dit il faut passer à autre
chose parce que la sécheresse va se
répéter alors c'est est-ce que vous
posez comme débat est un vrai débat la
vérité d'abord c'est une perte pour fond
donc ça peut être indemnisé la question
c'est est-ce on arrive à construire un
modèle qui permet de maintenir de
l'arboriculture et l'idée c'est à mon
avis oui sauf qu'il faudra se poser la
question qu'il y ait des pertes pour
récolte c'est pas une malheureusement
une nouveauté dans mon agricole c'est
l'histoire de du monde agricole que
d'avoir eu des aléas climatiques mais
quand on est sur un quelque chose qui
touche la plante elle-même mais si on
peut pas planter d'arbres fruitiers si
on peut pas planter de vigne je sais pas
ce qu'on peut en fait monsieur fauvette
c'est ça la difficulté donc on a besoin
d'avoir un système qui soit économe en
eau globalement et honnêtement la vigne
j'étais je visitais une exploitation
dans l'Aude il est tombé 90 mm depuis un
an 90 mm la plus géométrie normale dans
un pays comme le nôtre entre 500 et 600
mm la vigne était encore là
mais s'il pleut pas du tout elle va
disparaître et si j'ai pas ça
en fait la il y aura plus aucune
végétation donc on a besoin d'assurer
dans ce genre de département peut-être
d'un minimum de filet qui permettent non
pas de garantir tous les ans qu'on
produit mais de garantir au moins qu'on
puisse permettre le maintien d'un
certain nombre de productions il y a des
cultures prioritaires en termes d'eau en
termes de fond de il faut qu'on pense
notre système dans chaque territoire
avec ce que sera la la le potentiel de
pluie qui va tomber et est-ce que c'est
des territoires c'est les productions
qu'on a sont adaptées à la pluviométrie
ça veut dire qu'il y a des agriculteurs
à qui on va dire dans les semaines qui
viennent plus d'eau du tout tant pis la
priorité aujourd'hui c'est non
construire pardon ce qu'on essaie de
construire dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
et ce qui annoncera le préfet qui
continue à ses consultations j'aurais
vraiment saluer le travail à faire des
professionnels avec la préfecture pour
essayer de trouver un point d'équilibre
c'est qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
essaie de maintenir comme filet minimum
d'eau pour faire en sorte qu'il y a un
minimum de production parce qu'on a
quand même on est sur des productions
c'est des fruits et des légumes c'est de
l'arboriculture enfin bref c'est des
productions qui nous servent d'ailleurs
de ce département des
Pyrénées-Orientales en termes de
souveraineté est important pour la
France globalement qu'est-ce qui fait en
sorte qu'on préserve ce qu'on peut
préserver au minimum et qu'on préserve
aussi le potentiel de production pour
pas que des arbres disparaissent parce
que sinon c'est ça la difficulté mais
c'est vrai que c'est une équation
extrêmement compliquée de penser on est
déjà en agriculture méditerranéenne et
dans ces territoires le sujet n'est pas
de savoir si on a des des cultures qui
sont très consommatrices d'eau elles
sont très peu consommatrices d'eau déjà
ces cultures là mais comment on fait en
sorte de rendre le système encore plus
résilient est-ce que c'est des variétés
qui sont plus résistantes est-ce que
c'est un accès mais pour permettre que
l'outil de production soit maintenu
c'est tout ça qu'il faut la sécheresse
c'est ce qu'on va prioriser les
agriculteurs et créer des interdictions
pour les particuliers non mais vous
voyez bien que la batterie de mesure
comprend c'est des mesures alors
personne ne comprendrait qu'on dise
aucune interdiction pour personne sauf
pour les agriculteurs donc c'est bien un
effort collectif qu'on doit faire mais
voyez bien que la priorité c'est
l'aliment en eau potable et déclinant à
partir de l'alimentation en eau potable
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur le remplissage
des piscines qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur
des usages l'arrosage des des fleurs et
des jardins c'est peut-être moins
prioritaire que l'agriculture enfin
quand je dis c'est peut-être je suis
certain que c'est moins prioritaire que
dans les Pyrénées chacun de faire notre
part de l'effort dans cette affaire là
parler des piscines dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales le gouvernement a
annoncé l'interdiction de la vente des
piscines hors sol des piscines qu'on
ajoute dans dans son jardin pourquoi les
piscines hors-sol mais pas la
construction des piscines enterrées mais
les piscines enterrées elles-mêmes de
toute façon il y a une interdiction de
remplissage sauf qu'il y a un contrôle
qui est plus simple d'ailleurs sur des
piscines parce qu'il y a normalement en
bonne logique une déclaration
dans chaque quand vous êtes vous
construisez une piscine une déclaration
auprès de votre mère puisque ça fait
partie des éléments de la valeur d'un
bien et donc c'est plus facile à
contrôler qu'une piscine ensole c'est
pour tout le monde la règle va être la
même là c'est pour ne pas en rage
l'interdiction du remplissage des
piscines ça va être la règle sans doute
dans des dizaines de départements
[Musique]
que de dire quand vous n'avez plus d'eau
quand vous avez 100 mm d'eau qui tombe
sur un territoire de dire ben pardon
cette année on a besoin de prioriser
l'eau potable on a besoin de prioriser
des usages essentiels on a besoin de
prioriser on l'a pas dit mais dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales le pouvoir abreuver
les animaux c'est quand même plus
prioritaire que de remplir une piscine
et c'est pas une violence qui est faite
il faut qu'on s'adapte voilà alors après
il faut qu'on me semble-t-il il faut
qu'on gère l'urgence mais quand vous
êtes responsable public vous n'êtes pas
simplement à commenter le ici la
sécheresse là il y a trop d'eau vous
voyez c'est parce qu'on va avoir des
phénomènes climatiques atypiques on a
besoin de se projeter sur le moyen long
terme comme on fait en sorte de réduire
les fuites dans les réseaux d'eau il y a
un certain nombre d'endroits où on perd
50% de l'eau qui est consommé donc c'est
quand même fin qui est prélevé pardon
donc c'est quand même important d'y
travailler comment je fais essaie de
faire évoluer un modèle agricole mais
l'évolution du modèle agricole ça peut
pas être la disparition de l'agriculture
dans ces territoires là vous comprenez
bien que c'est sinon ça voudrait dire
qu'on laisse on laisse progresser une
forme de désert marcéno est-ce qu'avec
la sécheresse les Français doivent
s'attendre à payer leur fruits et
légumes plus cher cet été pas forcément
à date franchement on peut pas j'essaie
de pas d'ailleurs être dans le
catastrophique c'est parce que vous êtes
hein non plus mais je pose la question
ouais c'est pour ça que je dis vous ne
l'êtes pas donc je vous fais pas de
grève je dis on est à l'instant il n'y a
pas de hausse constaté sur les fruits et
légumes ne sont pas liés à la question
météorologique quelles sont les
principalement à la question
Ukraine augmentation des charges etc il
y a un sujet qu'on voit pas c'est que de
l'autre côté de la frontière des
Pyrénées à l'Espagne et comme on n'est
pas avec une très grosse sécheresse pour
le corps là pour le coup ils ont une
grosse sécheresse avec un système
d'eau qui commence à faire défaut pour
le modèle qui avait été construit sans
doute en partie là pour le coup et c'est
là qu'on a besoin de d'être souverain et
pas dépendre des autres parce que 50%
des fruits et légumes ils viennent de
l'extérieur de nos frontières et donc
quand il y a un problème dans un pays
comme l'Espagne qui est un éminent payé
en termes de production de fruits et
légumes ça ça peut avoir des
conséquences à l'été ça veut dire que
les producteurs français pourraient
tenter tirer les prix vers le haut
puisque des produits étranger espagnol
ou marocain augmente
si les producteurs français faisaient
les prises on serait heureux mais je
crois que dans les rapports alors dans
egalim on fait en sorte d'inverser un
peu le rapport de force mais c'est la
loi de l'offre et de l'Allemande et la
tension qui n'est sur les marchés elle
vient plutôt de ce que de ce qui
viennent demander aux producteurs des
choses c'est-à-dire plutôt la grande
distribution mais je jette de grève
personne chacun joue son rôle et essayer
d'anticiper des risques il y a une
mesure de la loi égaline qui est très
régulièrement critiquée notamment par
Michel-Edouard Leclerc c'est la mesure
qui oblige les grandes surfaces à
revendre 10% plus cher qu'elles ne les
ont acheté des produits alimentaires
c'était à l'origine pour sauver les
revenus garantir des revenus aux
agriculteurs est-ce que par période de
gros temps et d'inflation comme on la
connaît aujourd'hui avec une inflation
alimentaire de plus de 15% cette mesure
pourrait être provisoirement mise de
côté d'abord j'allais dire par une forme
de boutade si Michel Édouard Leclerc
n'est pas favorable faut déjà se
demander si du coup la mesure n'est pas
ne porte pas son intérêt si je pouvais
pas confiance en Lui non mais
n'avons pas le même type de combat le
combat de Michel-Edouard Leclerc c'est
le plus prébable mieux c'est sauf que
plus le prix est bas plus on fait
disparaître les producteurs et puis on
se retrouve dans la situation de perte
de souveraineté sur les fruits et
légumes par exemple sur le lait par
ailleurs et on peut avoir un dialogue
j'ai pas envie de faire Michel Édouard
Leclerc un bouc émissaire donc ça
m'intéresse pas de la de la jouer comme
ça pour être raisonnable avec vous mais
heureusement en revanche qu'on ait
besoin de rémunération c'est une chose
importante la question c'est par exemple
on pourrait pas passer à 5 % ce qui
permettait de réduire d'autant dès lors
que la grande distribution commencera à
rogner sur ses marges il n'est pas
démontré aujourd'hui que sur les marges
de la grande distribution en particulier
sur les fruits et légumes ou la marge
est assez importante il mange sur le bio
sur le BIOS sur le bio
souvent qui ont réduit leur marge c'est
ce que dit le rapport de Bercy il dit
que c'est plutôt donc les formes
maintenant il est justement
par exemple on sait très bien qu'on
marche beaucoup plus sur le bio dans la
grande distribution sur les produits
conventionnels si on voulait aider le
bio on ferait moins de marge on ferait
la marge du après tout pourquoi il y a
plus de marches sur le bureau que sur le
produit conventionnel parce que ça les
clients accepteraient plus qu'il y a une
marge plus importante donc chacun doit
faire sa part et la grande distribution
peut faire la sienne aussi il me
semble-t-il Marc phénoméniste de
l'agriculture invité de France Info
jusqu'à 9h il est 8h51 Maureen suignar
pour le fil info
ce n'est vraiment pas une urgence estime
sur France Info ce matin le député du
modèle Jean-Louis bourlange en cette
Journée de l'Europe une proposition de
loi du groupe Renaissance est examiné à
l'Assemblée pour rendre obligatoire le
drapeau européen sur les frontons des
mairies proposition rejetées par
l'opposition et qui divise donc aussi au
sein de la majorité les députés aussi
amenés à se prononcer sur cette
résolution pour classer le groupe
paramilitaire russe Wagner comme groupe
terroriste la Russie qui célèbre
aujourd'hui la victoire face à
l'Allemagne nazie défilé militaire alors
que l'armée étant difficulté sur le
terrain ukrainien la présidente de la
Commission européenne est à Kiev en ce
moment même pour apporter le soutien de
l'Union à l'Ukraine 300 nouveaux mots
dans le dictionnaire le Larousse et le
Robert s'enrichissent pour leur édition
2024 être en PLS crush megabassi ou
encore zone affaiblissement et puis le
choc du jour en football le Real Madrid
reçoit Manchester City à 21h demi-finale
aller de la Ligue des Champions à suivre
sur France Info
France Info
le 830 France Info Salia brachiha Mark
khaways dans dans un bras de fer contre
lands l'agence qui évalue les risques
des pesticides et qui délivre ou pas
l'émission le marché qu'est-ce que vous
lui reprochez
dans un bras de fer pardon de dire des
choses et qu'est-ce que je lui reproche
rien je dis juste que qu'est-ce qui nous
a amené parfois en situation de
difficulté pour l'agriculture française
c'est que dans un espace européen
prendre des décisions comme si nous
étions une île déserte mais c'est pas
l'ancêtre qui est en cause dans ce
registre
vous avez déclaré au sujet de l'ancêtre
et devant la FNSEA c'est l'heure de son
congrès je vous cite je ne serai pas le
ministre qui abandonnera des décisions
stratégiques pour notre souveraineté
alimentaire à la seule appréciation
d'une agence ajoute agence qui c'est moi
qui l'ajoute et aujourd'hui indépendante
puisque ce n'est pas votre ministère
elle n'est pas indépendante pardon c'est
pas une autorité indépendante c'est une
agence donc elle est sous votre autorité
tutelle de l'hémis à la culture du
ministère de la Santé du ministère et
c'est pas une insulte que d'avoir une
agence qui est sous tutelle ou côté
d'ailleurs y compris sur un certain
nombre de produits c'est le ministère de
l'Agriculture qui saisit lançais c'est
qui lui demande faire une analyse de
risque donc en revanche à chaque fois
c'est pondéré je vais vous donner deux
exemples sur lesquels c'est pondéré sur
la question de la grippe aviaire
l'anxess produit un avis la ville lances
parfois c'est de dire il faut confiner
l'ensemble des animaux bon j'ai une
demande parfois la Confédération
paysanne qui me dit il faut les laisser
sortir les animaux dans les élevages les
plus extensifs vous voyez bien
secondaire entre un avis et une réalité
donc c'est juste consultatif pour vous
n'essayez ce que j'ai pas dit je vois
bien ce que vous voulez m'emmener non ce
n'est pas juste consultatif et vous ne
m'avez jamais entendu dans aucune
déclaration remettre Enez laissez-moi
finir
comme disait l'autre vous n'avez jamais
vu remettre en cause la ville lancée sur
son fondement scientifique jamais non
mais jamais jamais jamais vous m'avez
entendu dire c'est par exemple en
revanche
rappelle pardon puissante herbicides
qu'on trouve notamment dans les eaux de
millions absolument de faire un avis et
vous dites jamais je n'ai dit que je
remettais en cause la ville lances parce
que je n'ai pas la compétence et ça
n'est pas mon tempérament je dis juste
on a une décision qui vient et on sait
qu'on a une décision devant nous qui a
une décision européenne
on est dans le même espace et dans le
même marché commun si c'est un produit
qui pose des problèmes j'espère j'estime
je pense que c'est pas idiot que ça se
passe dans le l'espace européen parce
que les produits européens ils
traversent la frontière vous dites c'est
pas vos oignons c'est à l'Europe de ça
jeudi on a besoin je dis juste qu'on
aurait besoin sur ce type de sujet de
mieux se coordonner et deuxième élément
je dis une deuxième chose c'est quand on
sait qu'on a un produit comme ça et
c'est tout le sens du plan la
planification qui a été voulu par le
Premier ministre et le président de la
République on a des molécules il y a la
moitié des molécules aujourd'hui
autorisées on sait qu'elles vont
repasser à la moulinette ou de lancer ou
de l'efta bref et c'est normal on
réévalue le risque parce qu'on les
données scientifiques sont nouvelles et
ils permettent de le faire est-ce qu'on
peut aussi se mettre en mode de on sait
qu'il y a un risque que cette molécule
disparaisse comment on trouve les
alternatives pour pas se retrouver en
situation
technique mais quand on sait que dans le
cas du S métola chlore par exemple on
sait que 3 millions et demi de Français
n'ont pas eu accès à une eau une eau
potable
j'en sais quelque chose
il faut arrêter ça d'accord très bien
mais est-ce qu'on est là pour importer
l'agriculture que nous ne voulons pas
c'est à dire que si ça produit un effet
qui est de la distorsion de trop grave
de concurrence aux frontières
européennes d'abord les produits
rentreront avec ce produit là qu'est-ce
qu'on a gagné et deux ça veut dire qu'on
ça veut dire ça sera pas dans dans les
nappes des autres et c'est pas grave ça
nous donne la bonne conscience si on
pousse la logique si on pousse la
logique ça veut dire qu'on accepte de
faire faire du textile dans des
conditions dégradées pour des êtres
humains ailleurs mais c'est pas grave
nous on est vertueux non le mieux c'est
quand même que nous on prenne les
adaptations nécessaires et les
transitions nécessaires jamais vous
m'entendrez sur le terrain vis-à-vis du
monde agricole de la facilité parce
qu'il y a besoin de transition mais on a
besoin de le faire en ordre européen ça
ne remet pas en cause les décisions
scientifiques de l'anxess jamais je ne
dis ça je dis juste est-ce qu'on peut
pas essayer de regarder quels sont les
alternatives qu'on a devant nous et
comment on fait en sorte de faire de la
planification quand on fait de
l'automobile de l'aérien du logement
tout le monde comprend qu'il faille 5 10
15 ou
diminution depuis 5 ans le bio en France
doublement des surfaces depuis 5 ans on
est le pays européen qui a plus de
surface en bio alors faut arrêter quand
même en permanence de dire de
l'agriculture ce qu'elle n'est pas et
c'est de dire le chemin qu'on a encore à
faire sur les questions d'eau sur les
questions de pesticides et il faut
travailler les alternatives j'étais avec
les députés européens hier soir du
groupe new pour dire avec Pascal Camphin
Jérémy de serre pour dire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on trouve comme
chemin pour se mettre dans la
trajectoire du la réduction des produits
phytosanitaires parce qu'il faut se
mettre dans cette trajectoire là un
dernier mot marque fait nous votre
nouvelle conseillère en communication
qui vous accompagne je crois ce matin en
régie ici à France Info connais très
bien l'industrie agroalimentaire
puisqu'elle était il y a quelques jours
encore directrice de la communication de
lanias et le lobby des intérêts de
l'industrie de l'agroalimentaire est-ce
que c'est gênant non et si elle avait
vous avez hésité à travailler pour des
gens qui faisaient du steak végétal ou
du steak de biologie musculaire ça vous
poserait pas de problème si c'était
quelqu'un qui avait travaillé pour elle
214 enfin c'est la même question je
crois non je pense pas que vous me posez
la question en tout cas
on aurait je crois que c'est le lobbies
comme un parieur l'industrie
agroalimentaire c'est des choses que
vous-même vous consommez tous les jours
consommer des bonbons est-ce que c'est
des gens qui sont toxiques à la santé
l'ombre d'un conflit d'intérêt un
troisième borne d'abord un est-ce qu'on
prend des gens compétents je peux aussi
prendre des gens qui n'y connaissent
rien je peux un chanteur d'opérette
alors comme ça il y aura pas de risque
de conflit d'intérêt et on n'aura pas de
procès en conflit d'intérêt on a besoin
on a besoin attendez on a besoin d'une
compétences et deuxième élément il y a
un truc vous savez comment ça s'appelle
pour le coup c'est une autorité
indépendante ça s'appelle la Haute
Autorité de transparence de la vie
publique qui sur chaque nomination dans
un ministère il y a pas beaucoup
d'endroits dans le monde où ça se passe
comme ça vous donne un avis vous dit
c'est compatible ou c'est pas compatible
donc je suis très heureux de l'avoir
parmi et la route autorité à donner un
feu vert complète a donné un feu vert
avec la borne de elle ne peut pas être
en contact avec son mais c'est normal
avec qui ne peut pas entrer avec son
précédent employeur mais c'est normal
c'est à dire
en communication elle va pas elle va pas
être en charge du dossier du cirago
alimentaire j'ai un autre conseiller qui
travaille sur l'industrie royale les
deux ne se parleront pas monsieur
monsieur Fauvel vous voyez bien que là
vous êtes un tout petit vous l'avez dit
vous-même merci c'est au jugé c'est pas
mal ministre de l'Agriculture
très bonne journée à vous